GO HOME TO THEIR FAMILIES. NOW,
THANK YOU. THAT WAS US
AMBASSADOR TO RUSSIA AND TRACY
AND WE'RE GETTING NEW DETAILS
THIS MORNING ABOUT AN ALLEGED
PLOT BY THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
TO SPY ON ALSO DO INTIMIDATE
CHINESE DISSIDENTS LIVING HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES OF THE FBI
YESTERDAY ANNOUNCED THE ARREST
OF TWO PEOPLE THEY SAY ARE
AGENTS OF CHINA WHO ARE RUNNING
A SECRET AND ILLEGAL POLICE
STATION RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF
NEW YORK CITY, RIGHT IN LOWER
MANHATTAN, THE PYRAMID, THEIR
FIRST APPEARANCE IN COURT
YESTERDAY. THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ALSO CHARGED 34
OFFICERS OF CHINA'S NATIONAL
POLICE AND PLOTS TARGETING
PEOPLE LIVING HERE IN THE US
JOINING US OUR CNN CHIEF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND INTELLIGENCE
ANALYST JOHN MILLER. JOHN, THIS
HAS BEEN DISCUSSED A LOT PRIOR
TO THIS QUESTIONS TO CITY
OFFICIALS ABOUT WHETHER THIS WAS
HAPPENING HERE IN NEW YORK. NOW
THE FEDS SAY THIS IS HAPPENING.
ARE THERE MORE? AND WHAT DOES IT
MEAN? WELL THERE'S 100 OF THESE
CHINESE POLICE OUTPOSTS AROUND
THE WORLD HUMAN RIGHTS GROUP DID
A STUDY FROM THE NETHERLANDS
CANADA WHEREVER THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT CHINESE EXPAT
COMMUNITY. ONE OF THESE QUIET
POLICE SUBSTATIONS HAS OPENED
UP. SO DURING AN INTERVIEW WITH
THE FBI, ONE OF THE ACCUSED
AGENTS SAID THAT HE HAD
ESTABLISHED THE OFFICE TO HELP
CHINESE NATIONALS LIVING IN THE
UNITED STATES RENEW THEIR
CHINESE GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS. IS
THAT WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT
EXPLANATION? I THINK THAT IS A
PERFECTLY LOGICAL EXPLANATION,
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE TRYING TO
GATHER METADATA INFORMATION,
PERSONAL INFORMATION ON AN EXPAT
COMMUNITY UM SAYING YOU CAN COME
IN HERE AND ESTABLISH YOUR
IDENTIFICATION NAME. DATE OF
BIRTH WILL GET YOUR DRIVER'S
LICENSE TAKEN CARE OF BACK IN
CHINA. IT'S A GREAT WAY TO
FIGURE OUT OKAY, LET'S MAKE A
LIST WHO'S ON THE GROUND? YOU'RE
GETTING A LOT OF DATA. WHEN
SOMEBODY COMES IN TO FILL OUT.
YOU KNOW A DRIVER'S LICENSE FOR
HIM. IT'S A WAY TO LURE THEM
EXACTLY, BUT I MEAN, THESE ARE
VERY COMPLICATED OPERATIONS, SO
TO UNDERSTAND THE BREATH OF THIS
. YOU HAVE CHINESE AGENTS
ATTEMPTING TO RECRUIT NEW YORK
CITY CHINESE POLICE OFFICERS. UM
AS YOU KNOW, AS SUB AGENTS, YOU
HAVE CHINESE POLICE OFFICERS
GOING OUT THROUGHOUT NEW YORK,
BUT BEYOND THEIR INTO THE
SUBURBS, VISITING CHINESE EXPATS
SAYING YOU'VE BEEN POSTING BAD
THINGS ON TWITTER OR SOCIAL
MEDIA ABOUT CHINA AND YOU WERE
IN TROUBLE AND THIS COULD AFFECT
YOUR FAMILY AT HOME AND YOU NEED
TO STOP. OR CONVERSELY, YOU NEED
TO COME BACK TO CHINA OR BAD
THINGS ARE GOING TO HAPPEN TO
YOUR FAMILY. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE WENT THROUGH IN THE NYPD
WHEN I WAS RUNNING THE INTEL
PROGRAM, THERE WAS UM, A LOT OF
WORK WITH THE CHINESE COUNCIL
GENERAL IN NEW YORK, SAYING WE
WANT TO SIGN AN MOU WITH THE
NYPD, SAYING THAT OUR OPERATIONS
ARE COOPERATING. AND YOU KNOW,
IN DISCUSSIONS WITH THE FBI,
THEY SAID THEY USED THESE
LETTERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY WITH
OTHER POLICE TO SAY NO, WE WORK
WITH THE NYPD. YOU KNOW, WE'RE
HERE ON THE GROUND WITH